This is Britain through my eyes.
For me, classical music, it's life. It's not work.
Today, I think England is one of the strongest classical music places.
You look at Time Out magazine...
...and you have, I don't know, four or five events that you really want to go to.
It's incredible, the amount of different directions you can go.
You can go into jazz, you can go into early music, you can go with anything.
The first memory, I think I was six and I played in the Bolshoi Theatre, a big hall with an orchestra.
And I played, I think, every year for three or four years.
I wasn't nervous, particularly.
It was, of course at the age of six, you don't realize that the Bolshoi Theatre is important.
So, it was easy. It was fine.
My father got an invitation to play in the London Symphony Orchestra.
So, we all decided to move to England, which of course was a big step for everyone, I think.
My mother or me, we didn't even see the house we were going to live in at that time. We just turned up.
So, I went to a music school, the Yehudi Menhuin School.
And I auditioned and got in at the age of 11...
And of course, as every other child, I loved to perform but not to practice.
And the Menhuin School gave me the ground to decide which way I wanted to go.
It's funny. It seems so much smaller.